Okay, danke.
Bitte schön.
Danke. Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Sista Ersin und ich bin der Assistant auf dieser Station.
Ich würde gerne das Aufnahmengeschrieb mit Ihnen führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, gerne, Frau Doktor.
Bevor Sie mir über Ihre Beschwerden erzählen, würde ich gerne am Anfang
einfach allgemeine Fragen stellen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Franz Josef Strauss.
Strauss ist der Nachname.
Können Sie bitte vornehmen und nachnehmen?
Franz, Franz, Franz, Franz.
Okay.
Und dann Josef, J, O, S, E, F.
F, am Ende, okay.
Und der Nachname ist Strauss, S, T, R, A, U.
Strauss ist der Nachname.
Okay.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 65 Jahre alt.
Ich bin geboren am 1. Februar 1957.
1957.
Ersin, Februar.
Ja.
Können Sie mir bitte verraten, wie groß Sie sind
und wie viel Sie wissen?
Ich bin jetzt, ich war einmal 1,75 m.
Und wie geht es aktuell so ungefähr 67 kg?
67 kg.
So heißt das.
Was für Sie uns?
Das Problem, das ich habe, ist, dass ich zunehmend Luftnot habe
und ich habe das nicht mehr.
Bei kleinster Einstrengung kann ich jetzt nicht mehr richtig atmen.
Und habe Hustenreiz und auch Auswurf.
Es hat auch zugenommen.
Also ich muss dazu sagen, dass ich schon längere Zeit
mit der Luftprobleme habe.
Seit wann haben Sie Luftprobleme?
Also ungefähr seit, ja, 5, 6 Jahren ungefähr,
habe ich schon Luftprobleme.
Seitdem habe ich auch so Sprays von meinem Lungenarzt bekommen.
Und jetzt ist aber das seit ein paar Tagen jetzt ganz schlimm geworden,
sodass ich kaum noch laufen kann.
Also weil ich auf die und paar Schritte laufen,
ist die Luft weg.
Also fast schon in Ruhe habe ich auch schon beschwerten.
Und das hatte ich ja gesagt, dass jetzt...
Hat es Sie auch im Ruhigstand beschwarten?
Also wenn ich jetzt mit Ihnen spreche, wenn ich länger spreche,
habe ich auch da schon Luftprobleme, ja.
Ist die Luft abhängig davon, ob Sie setzen, legen oder bewegen laufen?
Ja, also bei bewegen laufen wird die mehr, ja.
Deswegen kann ich auch kaum noch laufen.
Wie viele Stoffe können Sie steigen ohne Luftnot zu bekommen?
Also bevor es jetzt so schlimm wurde, habe ich immer so ein Stockwerk geschafft,
weil ich habe mein Schlafzimmer im ersten Stock im Haus.
Und das ging noch so, das habe ich immer noch ganz gut hinbekommen.
Mehr als ein Stockwerk wurde schwierig.
Aber jetzt seit 2, 3 Tagen, wie gesagt, habe ich starke Luftnot,
da kann ich keine Treppen streigen.
Deswegen schlafe ich auch unten im Wohnzimmer.
Okay. Können Sie hinlegen ohne Luftnot zu bekommen?
Das geht noch so, ja.
Wie viele Kissen benutzen Sie beim Schlaf?
Eigentlich nur einen Kissen immer.
Ein Kissen immer.
Haben Sie in der Nacht auch Luftnot?
Ja, also seit 2 Tagen habe ich auch Nachtprobleme, ja.
Nachtprobleme.
Können Sie wegen diesen Beschwerden aufstehen?
Oder aufwachen?
Ja, manchmal war ich aufhören.
Sie haben mir gesagt, dass Sie Auswurf haben.
Können Sie mir bitte Ihren Auswurf gehen,
aber beschreiben, ist es schleimig?
Also es ist viel schleim, ja.
Ich habe schon seit Jahren immer auch rusten.
Auswurf, jetzt seit 2 Tagen, es ist viel mehr geworden
und es ist auch verferbt, gelblich, dunkelgelb.
Wie war es früher?
Es war immer eher weiß-hell, gelb bis dunkelgelb.
Herr Struos, Sie haben mir gesagt,
dass Sie seit 5, 6 Jahren unter Behandlung sind.
Wissen Sie Ihre Diagnose?
Wie heißt Ihre Diagnose?
Das weiß ich nicht genau,
er sagt, es ist Lungenkrankheit,
aber es kommt vom Rauchen,
hat mir der Lungenarzt gesagt.
Okay, können es sein, dass Sie COPD haben?
Wissen Sie?
Kann sein, aber ich habe nicht gemerkt,
was er gesagt hat.
Okay, wir gucken mal gleich.
Wie viel rauchen Sie?
Also ich habe letztes Jahr aufgehört,
ich habe letztes Jahr einen Herzinfarkt gehabt.
Dann habe ich aufgehört, davor habe ich viel geraucht, leider.
Wie viele Jahre haben Sie geraucht?
Ich habe mit 19, 20 angefangen und dann bis letztes Jahr,
also sicherlich so 40 Jahre, über 40 Jahre.
Okay, wie viel Verkauf am Tag haben Sie geraucht?
Zuletzt war es nicht mehr so viel,
es war eine Packung davor, aber auch schon mal mehr gewesen.
Eineinhalb Packungen, ja.
Eineinhalb bis eine Packung kann man ungefähr sagen.
Ja, wir kommen zurück, so ihre Becher werden.
Ich habe nicht gemerkt, wo ich auswurfe,
sie haben Luft.
Also wenn ich huste, habe ich auch dann auch Beklemmungsgefühl,
damit die Brust ein bisschen eng ist,
dann habe ich das Gefühl, ich weiß nicht, ob das wichtig ist,
aber vielleicht bild ich mir auch nur ein.
Haben Sie Schmerzen beim Aussatmen und Einatmen?
Schmerzen nicht, aber wenn ich viel huste, dann tut es dann hier weh.
Sind Ihre husten anfahlartig, zu rocken oder schleimig?
Also das letzte Tag ist viel schleimiger.
Wie oft husten Sie ganzen Tag?
Das kann ich jetzt so nicht sagen, es dauert eigentlich.
Die ganze Zeit huste ich.
Haben Sie früher oder wie war Ihre husten früher,
waren es nur morgens?
Ja, aber früher morgens mehr, mit Auswürfen,
dann, wir haben einen Tag weniger, haben sie echt.
Okay.
Herr Strasse, haben Sie viel Ball?
Ich habe jetzt nicht gemessen, aber so gefühlt nicht, nein.
Ich konnte die richtige Antwort nicht bekommen.
Haben Sie beim Aussatmen und Einatmen Schmerzen?
Ist es Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Sie Schmerzen haben?
Kann ich so nicht sagen, nein.
Okay.
Ich habe eine Frage, die Sie haben gesagt.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Also ist weniger geworden, seit dem letzten Jahr,
wo ich diesen Herzinfarkt habe, habe ich dann auch abgenommen.
Da habe ich ungefähr 5-6 kg abgenommen, also der Appetit ist ein bisschen weniger geworden.
5-6 kg abgenommen.
Das letzte Jahr?
Haben Sie Probleme mit Ihrem Verdaumsystem?
Kann ich so nicht sagen, nein.
Haben Sie Unfertiglichkeiten?
Leiden Sie unter Verstopfung durchwahl?
Nein, nein, habe ich keine Probleme gehabt bisher.
Können Sie durchlaufen, einschlafen, haben Sie Probleme mit dem Schlafen?
Also bisher nicht, aber seit 2 Tagen haben Sie ja schon gesagt,
habe ich da Schwierigkeiten in der Luft, da kann ich auch nicht so gut schlafen.
Herr Stas, haben Sie Probleme beim Wasser lassen?
Eigentlich nicht, nein.
Haben Sie dicke Beine?
Nein, meine Beine sind dünn.
Keine Ödermin?
Keine Wasser in den Beinen.
Ist Ihre Ausbrüfe schleimig?
Schaumig? Nein, nein.
Ist es nicht so normaler Schleim?
Ist es Ihnen aufgefallen, dass es eine Auslöser für Ihre Husten gibt?
Das Rauchen, denke ich mal, dass das die Ursache war.
Oder meinen Sie jetzt, dass das neue Problem jetzt aktuell?
Nein, ich weiß nicht, nein, ich habe nichts anderes gemacht oder gegessen oder so.
Das sind Sie uns über Ihre Vorgeschichte beschrieben.
Leiden Sie an Konkretner Kranken?
Ich weiß nicht, ob es gründliche Krankheit ist, aber ich habe Blutdruck.
Ja, wie Blutdruck.
Blutdruck habe ich gestätzt worden, letztes Jahr, als ich den Herzenfakt hatte.
Ich habe auch Medikamente bekommen gegen Blutdruck.
Ich bin nicht operiert worden, aber am Blinddarm.
Am Blutdarm, wann?
Ich habe das Handgelenk gebrochen, da war mal eine Metallplatte drin.
Metallplatte?
Ja.
Wann war diese Operation?
Das war vor 20 Jahren.
Vor 20 Jahren.
Sie haben auch ein Herzinfarkt erlitten?
Ja, letztes Jahr.
Haben Sie bei Ihnen Kornerangiografi durchgeführt?
Ja, sie haben einen Katheter gemacht, dann haben sie auch Stents gesetzt.
Also Sie haben einen Stents?
Ja, zwei sogar glaube ich.
Ein oder zwei?
Zwei, meine ich.
Ich würde gerne Ihre Medikamente fragen.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie gegen Ihr Blutdruck ein?
Da habe ich einmal das Ramilisch.
Ich denke Ramilisch heißt das.
5 Minigrammen.
Dann habe ich Biso Prololl.
2,5 Minigrammen morgens und abends.
Dann habe ich noch, aber nicht gegen den Hochdruck,
das ist wegen Herzinfarkt, habe ich Sortis bekommen.
Dann nehme ich eine Tablette abends ein.
Dann habe ich noch bekommen Aspirin, muss ich einnehmen.
Und Plavix, das hat mir der Arzt gesagt,
darf ich nicht weglassen wegen dem Stent.
Ja.
Dann habe ich noch seit einigen Jahren dieses Inhalation.
Ultipro.
Ich habe immer einen Hub, einen Hub morgens mache ich dann immer.
Und dann habe ich noch als Notfallspray vom Herz bekommen.
Salbo Tamol, das habe ich jetzt auch genommen, aber hat nicht so viel geholfen.
Salbo Tamol.
Ich möchte Sie mir bitte die name,
ihre inhalation,
inhalation, Ultipro.
Ultipro.
Und wissen Sie, wogegen Sie Sortis einnehmen?
Das haben die mir nach dem Herzinfarkt gegeben.
Sortis.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das mit Cholesterin, irgendwas,
war damit Cholesterin, glaube ich.
Okay.
Haben Sie Hochblutwärtswerte?
Weiß ich nicht.
Okay, Herr Stras.
Sind bei Ihnen allergin bekannt?
Allergien habe ich keine, nein.
Haben Sie Unverzweglichkeiten?
Nein.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Gegen Corona bin ich vollständig geimpft, ja.
Andere Impfungen?
Weiß ich nicht mehr, also schon lange her die anderen Impfungen, glaube ich.
Sind Sie reimer geimpft?
Ja.
Okay.
Herr Stras, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Früher habe ich mal getrunken, seitdem ich Herzinfarkt habe,
habe ich rauchen, Alkohol, habe ich komplett weggelassen.
Herr Stras, ich verarmute die Antwort schon,
aber das ist eine Routinefrage, deswegen muss ich fragen,
haben Sie Kontakt mit den Drogen?
Nein, nicht mit den Drogen.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie wichtige Krankheiten,
von denen ich wissen sollte?
Also mein Vater, der hat es an Magenkrebs gestorben.
Meine Mutter ist auch verstorben,
die hatte Herzinfarkt, aber hat auch Zucker und Bluthochdruck.
Ansonsten kann ich jetzt mal eine Geschwister,
die sind eines Eltern, eines Jüngers, die haben auch ein paar Erkrankungen,
aber ich weiß nicht genau, was sie haben.
Wie Bluthochdruck oder Zuckerkrankheit?
Ich weiß nicht ob.
Oder kann es sein, dass die Krebs haben? Nein.
Und die Krebs nicht? Nein.
Okay.
Ist Ihr Familienzustand?
Familienstand?
Ja, also ich bin feieradet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, drei Kinder.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, Sie sind gesund.
Gut.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Also ich bin seit drei Jahren in Vorurstand
und habe davor in der Fabrik gearbeitet,
der Autoindustrie, weil ich war bei Opel.
Was war Ihre Aufgabe?
Also ich habe Montage gemacht.
So Türen haben wir montiert.
Hatten Sie damals Kontakt mit den giftigen Farben
oder Chemikalischedinge?
Ich habe nicht in der Lackierei gearbeitet,
aber andere Stoffe kann ich jetzt so nicht sagen.
Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube nicht.
Okay.
Okay Herr Strasz, ich bin fertig mit meinen Fragen.
Haben Sie noch Fragen an mich?
Denken Sie, dass ich wieder mit der Luft besser werde?
Oder was meinen Sie?
Ja, ich glaube es wird besser nach der richtige Diagnose
und Behandlung.
Die werden wieder besser.
Und muss ich im Krankenhaus bleiben?
Okay.
Jetzt werde ich dir eine kleine transformed by in anbrut abnehmen und rundken filmen veranlasen.
Ehe Bruce röntgen filmen veranlasen umsonst eine solche, die für dich sind nicht
mehr princess und wieder über ihre Diagnose und behahren.
Okay.
Dann Bhene bir susam leinchen, Schaden obsi eh hier bleiben oder na ha ha ha sesi
Sahin.
Okay.
Danke sehr.
Danke.
So, gibt es Fragen oder Kommentare?
Haben Sie die Oedemien Ihrer Beine bemerkt?
Hat Sie gefragt? Keine Oedeme?
Weitere Fragen?
Haben Sie Weinschmerzen zum Beispiel?
Weinschmerzen, Weinschmerzen.
Weinschmerzen? Hat er keine gehabt?
Keine Weinschmerzen, ja.
Ich habe nicht gefragt, ob Sie Blut im Auswurf bemerkt haben.
Hat er gesagt, dass man nur gelblich hat.
Kein Blut, ja.
Was hätte man noch fragen können?
Also im Hinblick auf die Verdassdiagnose.
Was ist Ihre Verdassdiagnose?
Ich habe am Anfang, wie heißt das, Diopädie?
Ja.
Ich habe Diopädie gehört, gell?
Also, hat Diopädie.
Es ist eine Erbastion.
Richtig, ex-Azibiatrikanin hat Diopädie.
Das ist die Verdassdiagnose.
Was kann man bei solchen Sachen noch mal fragen?
Ja, ich habe aber viel,
ich habe die Patientin, der Patient hat keinen Färber.
Deswegen am Ende das Autoindustrie.
Lasst mich an Berufskrankheit denken.
Kann sein, aber wenn die viel geraucht haben,
dann ist unwahrscheinlich das Berufskrankheit.
Als Differenzdiagnose kommt Branche,
als Insuffizienz in Betracht.
Was sollte man, wenn die Patienten das nicht sagen,
noch gezielt fragen bei ex-Azibiatrikanin?
Ex-Azibiatrikanin, ich habe die Frage.
Denken Sie mal an die Klassifikation der Diopädie.
Das ist sehr speziell, international.
Denken Sie mal an.
Kennen Sie die Klassifikation bei Diopädie?
Sag dir etwas.
Die Gold-Klassifikation.
Gold, Kennen Sie das?
G-O-L-D-Klassifikation.
Dann gibt es noch so,
kann man eintreten mit Gold 1 bis 4.
Dann gibt es noch diese Buchstaben, A, B, C, D.
Wissen Sie, was das bedeutet?
Gold 1 statt 3a, 2b.
Nein, schon im Moment da, nichts ein.
Es ist auch speziell, ich sage es nur,
dass die Buchstaben beinhalten,
die Symptome des Patienten,
ob er stark symptomatisch ist von der Natur Pd.
Und die zweite Sache ist,
wie oft er Ex-Azibationen hatte.
Ex-Azibationen kann man oft fragen,
indem man fragt, waren Sie deswegen schon mal dieses Jahr,
oder im Krankenhaus gewesen, wegen der gleichen Probleme.
Das hatte ich noch gefragt.
Wenn er es nicht selbst sagt, natürlich.
Das ist ein Hinweis auf Ex-Azibations-Präfigkeit.
Das ist dann auch wichtig,
dass man die Medikamententherapie dann auch anpassen kann.
Okay, sonst noch Kommentare fragen?
Ex-Azibationen, nein.
Dann gehen wir zur Oberarztvorstellung, würde ich sagen.
Bitte schön.
Bitte.
Wie können wir fragen oder sagen
zur Patienten-Azibation?
Nicht Fachbegriff?
Die Ex-Azibation, meinen Sie?
Ich habe es nicht ganz verstanden.
Ja, COPD-Ex-Azibation.
Wie können wir erklären
zur Patienten-Azibation?
Mit welchem Wort?
Es geht darum zu fragen,
ob er schon mal die gleichen Probleme hatte.
Letzter Zeit, letzten Monat, letzten Jahr.
Können wir Anfall sagen?
Kann man sagen,
oder hatten Sie schon mal so ähnliche Verstechtigung
Ihrer beschwerden Luftnot-Husten gehabt?
Letzten Monaten, letzten Jahr,
so würde ich das fragen.
Und waren Sie deswegen schon mal beim Ars oder im Krankenhaus?
Ja, danke.
Okay, dann machen wir Oberarztvorstellung.
Bitte schön.
Ich habe einen neuen Patient aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne diesen Patientinnen
vorstellen.
Hätten Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Bitte schön, ja.
Danke.
Herr Franz Josef Schittraus ist ein 75-Jahr-
65.
Ich bin ein 75-Jahr-
Patient.
Ich bin bei uns bei
5-6
2-3 Tagen
von Sundarien
mit Auswurfbegleitenden
Begleitenden
Begleitenden.
Die Frage,
der Patient hat auslern berichtet,
dass sein Auswurf
schleimlich und gelbig geworden sei.
Er hat auslern
ein brustengelses Gefühl.
Und vorhanden
des Patienten
hat man schon 6 Jahre
vom Puhr一樣 zubereitet.
Er hat seit den 2-3 Tagen
veo
Wir sind bewegend und verschlechtert bei der Bewegung.
Und wenn der Patient die Treppen nicht steigen kann,
die Frage, der Patient hat auch Särden klackt über eine ähnliche Dispne.
Eine ähnliche Dispne.
Ja, die Frage nach Fieber wurde verneint.
In der vegetative Analyse ist es erwinsverdas der Patient 5-6 kg abgenommene Hatt.
Hatt-Araben, Anzosen, keine Auffälligkeiten.
Als Vorerkrankung hat der Patient seit einem Jahr arteriellen Hepatone
erneut die Gegendereinbril 5 mg ein.
Der Patient hat vor einem Jahr ein Herzinfarkt erlitten.
Koronialangiografie wurde bei dem Patient durchgeführt und er hat 2 Stente bekommen.
Deswegen nimmt er 7 Tag bis 2,5 mg 2 Mal am Tag, Zortis 1 Mal am Tag, Aspirin und Plovix 1 Mal am Tag.
Beide Jugendlich wurde im Opentic to Medutch geführt.
Vor 20 Jahren hat er nach dem Handgelenkfraktur Osteosynthesis und er leidet an seit 5-6 Jahren COPD.
Gegen COPD nimmt er Multi-Pro Hub, Sprejota Hub, und Sarbutomol, Inhalation, Beinbedarf.
Der Patient ist extra für ihn. Er hat zwischen 20 und 65 Lebensjahren 1,5 Mal am Tag geraucht.
Er raucht nicht und trinkt kein Alkohol seit einem Jahr.
Er hat keinen Kontakt mit den Drogen. Der Patient ist verheiratet, hat 3 Gesundheitkinder.
Seit 3 Jahren ist er Rentner.
Vorher hat er bei Opel beim Autoindustrie gearbeitet.
Er ist in der Familie in Anamnese.
Er wird erwähnt, dass sein Vater an Maghankars non gestorben ist und seine Mutter an Herzinfarkt gestorben ist.
Seine Mutter hat außerdem Gehwetes Melutos und arterialen Hepatone.
Sie hat 2 Geschwister. Sie leiden auch an Königinakrankungen, aber der Patient hat darüber keinen Bescheid.
Aus Anamnestischen Angaben vermute ich bei dem Patienten eine COPD Exoservation.
Aus Anamnestischen Angaben vermute ich die COPD Exoservation.
Ja, man sieht, man sieht 2 Enzyme.
Was machen Sie mit den Patienten?
Ich würde erst den Patienten körperlich untersuchen,
Vitalparameter überprüfen, sein Fieber messen und seine Lunge abholen.
Was erwarten Sie beim Abhören?
Abhören erwarten Rasulgeräusche.
Weil eine Exoservation händelt sich um.
Was ist bei der COPD typisch?
Ja, wir sind die Gemurmen.
Wenn Sie feuchte Rasulgeräusche hören, was ist das für den Hinweis?
Phenomenie.
Es kann natürlich anders sein, wenn es eine Pneumonie hat.
Aber wenn es eine exoservierte COPD ist, würde ich nicht unbedingt für die Rasulgeräusche erwarten.
Es sei denn erst stark verschleunen, dann kann es auch mal solche ausklatschungsbefundene Kinder normalerweise geben, brummen.
Wenn es eine schwere COPD ist, kann man dann hören?
Stridorf.
Nein.
Stridorf? Ja, kann sein.
Was kann man noch hören?
Wiesink.
Das ist das, was Sie gesagt haben, glaube ich, mit dem Bohr.
Was kann man hören oder auch nicht hören, sage ich jetzt mal?
Atembronschialgeräusche.
Phamin der Atemgeräusche.
Anfisematös.
Hat jemand schon hier reingeschrieben, was man dann hört?
Ja, ich habe es schon mal ergeben.
Sie nennt man das auf Englisch, gibt es einen Fachbegriff dafür, den man oft benutzt, zeitendlang.
Also dass man kaum Atemgeräusche hört, weil einfach der Patient es zu stark empfüßieren hat,
das ist gar nichts.
Dann hören Sie nur ganz geringes Atemgeräusch, wenn überhaupt.
Silent chest oder Stummelunge.
Genau, manchmal bei schwere COPD.
Gut, dann haben Sie abgehört.
Sie haben jetzt Bromund Given festgestellt bei den Patienten.
Also passt zu einer bronchospastischen Komponente.
Und was machen Sie noch mit den Patienten?
Wenn der Patient Plural Ergust oder Plural Ephusion hat, kann ich bei der Palpation das bestimmen.
Ist es häufig Plural Ergust bei extra COPD?
Nein, nicht häufig.
Wenn der Patient chronische Infektion hat, habe ich gesagt.
Aber ja, es ist nicht häufig.
Also eher unwahrscheinlich, oder?
Ja, sehr unwahrscheinlich.
Aber was können Sie noch machen?
Haben Sie abgehört, haben Sie Vitalparameter bestimmt abgehört?
Was machen Sie noch?
Ich werde Blut abnehmen, um die Entsundungquartee zu bestimmen,
wenn der Patient Exzelsarvation hat, die Entsundungquartee sind erhöht.
Ja, und auch Blutbild ist wesentlich.
Bei der Blutbildseehe ist Lokostosis.
Und Blutgasanalyse kann auch sinnvoll sein.
Das weist auf respiratory Insufficiency hin.
Ja, richtig.
Also Blutgasanalyse, was machen Sie noch?
Ja, Röntgenaufnahme, ich bräuchte eine große Rolle bei Diagnon.
Sie haben eine Lokostose erhöhtes CRP, also wie es passt.
Die Blutgasanalyse zeigt ein leichter Hypoxemie.
Und was machen Sie mit den Patienten jetzt?
Jetzt, bei der Blutgasanalyse, wenn der Patient Hypoxie hat,
die Sauerstoffgabe ist indiziert.
Ja, wenn die Entsundungquartee erhöht sind
und der Patient Lokostose hat, dann kommt Antibioseterapie zum Einsatz.
Und für die symptomatische Therapie würde ich bei den Patienten Bronchodilatöre
und Mucolytica Therapie einsetzen.
Was noch, wenn der darunter nicht besser wird oder stark im Tomat?
Was kann man da noch machen?
Ja, intensiv ist es, ja, Steroids, oder Mechanikventilator, SIPAP.
So schlimm ist es noch nicht, aber klar, das kann passieren.
Aber richtig, also Steroidtherapie, kurzzeitige Steroidtherapie für 3 Tage zum Beispiel.
Alles klar, gucken wir mal im Chat nach, ob da irgendwelche Kommentare oder Fragen sind.
Spyriometrie, ja, Lungfunktion, kann man sich echt machen, um die Diagnose zu verpüren.
Und Gimel-Brumm-Stummelung-Steroidtherapie, und jetzt die schwere Grage der Goldklassifikation aufgeschrieben.
Okay.